bonjour génie de l'internet c'est
bienvenu dans cette vidéo sur un célèbre
auteur pas toujours patriotique mais aux
apports bénéfiques à la littérature qui
tel un automate bien que parfois frugal
à apporter au monde la quintessence du
gymnaste et de ses alter 20 secondes de
vidéo c'est déjà le bordel chute
aliénor si vous vous étonnez de mon
langage c'est normal jenny célèbre
patriotique bénéfique aux tomates rugal
quintessence gymnastes alter tous ces
montants commun d'être des néologisme
inventé par françois rabelais le mec a
porté à peu près 800 mo à la langue
française ce qui n'est pas mal et il
n'est pas le seul d'autres auteurs comme
ronsard par exemple on inventer des mots
qu'ils soient encore utilisé aujourd'hui
on n'est pas ici pour parler des mots
proprement parler mais je trouvais cette
introduction plutôt swag probablement
dérivé du verbe to swagger inventé par
shakespeare shakespeare ça inspire on va
plutôt parler d'astrologie aujourd'hui
parce que rabelais était médecin et au
16e siècle comme au siècle précédent
beaucoup de médecins étaient aussi
astrologue le lien entre les deux était
assez fort cf la vidéo sur l'astrologie
si vous voulez en savoir plus mais elle
apparaîtra quelque part en gros la
grande majorité des astrologues était à
la base médecin de formation avait
choisi une spécialité astrologie ensuite
rappelé n'échappe pas à cette règle et
se présentent parfois comme astrologues
si j'ai choisi de faire cette vidéo
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'entre 1532 et
1540 de rabelais écrit les plantes à
gruel dean pronostics à sion il s'agit
d'un horoscope qui reprend tous les
codes de la prédiction annuel tel qu'on
en trouve au moyen âge et on enverra une
véritable à la fin de la vidéo en
parodie il parodie complètement le genre
et c'est drôle c'est assez intéressant à
analyser
j'ai eu l'idée de faire cette vidéo
parce que je suis allé visiter la maison
natale de rabelais du côté de tours
quand j'étais parti à montbazon cet été
et c'était génial parce que déjà la
maison est magnifique et en plus j'avais
pas de faire des gestes mais ma pardon
et en plus je suis tombé sur une
exposition rabelais et nostradamus
astrologie d'apt 1 et c'était génial
donc parce que c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse beaucoup puisque j'ai
travaillé là dessus
dans cette vidéo on va donc lire les
pentes à graignes
pronostics à sion qui est un texte assez
court même si j'ai choisi quelques
morceaux à tout lire non plus et le
commenter j'ai essayé d'apporter des
éléments scientifiques par rapport à ce
que je sais et d'interpréter certaines
choses bon j'ai déjà une fois ça sera
pas du live complet mais
c'est une vidéo qui est semi improvisée
pas tout n'est pas préparée donc c'est
parti je regarde par là parce que le
texte des pronostics à sion et par là
pardon pantagruel d'une pronostics à
sion certaines véritable est infaillible
pour l'en perpétuelle nouvellement
composé au profit et a vivement de jean
étourdi et musard de nature par m
alcofribas archi triclin dudit
pantagruel alors déjà et plusieurs
choses à noter sur cette introduction il
nous parle d'un perpétuel ce qui est un
peu idiot puisque les prédictions
étaient des horoscopes annuel basé pour
un an par rapport à la position des
étoiles sur un an
une prédiction perpétuelle n'est pas
possible en astrologie nous explique
aussi que cette prédiction est faite au
profit des gens étourdi et musard de
nature qui entre aussi en contradiction
avec les vrais prédictions annuel qui
elle était faite au profit de rois de
prince de duke et donc pas du tout les
pauvres les premiers décors venues
ensuite il nous dit que cette prédiction
a été faite par m alcofribas et là le
choix du nom est intéressant aussi parce
que ça nous vient des noms arabes
des astrologues des xvème xvième siècle
comme 14e s'inspirer des travaux des
scientifiques arabes des 12è 13è siècle
et comme en europe occidentale on
francise et les noms des auteurs arabes
on se retrouve avec des scientifiques
qui s'appelait par exemple album hasard
ça c'est un vrai astrologue arabe est
donc là il a choisi de parodier ça en
l'appelant alcofribas qu'une petite
référence à des vrais scientifiques
arabes et enfin se mettre alcofribas est
décrit comme l'archi tréclun de
pantagruel est archi triclin en fait
c'est le mec qui organise des festins ça
n'a rien à voir avec l'astrologie
du nombre d'or lundi tours je m'en
trouve point cette année quelques quatre
îles à sion que j'en ai fait à son autre
verte et volume alors le nombre d'or en
astrologie il a une signification c'est
le rang d'une année dans le cycle de
mettons c'est un cycle qui comporte dix
neuf années et qui est basée sur le
cycle solaire et lunaire donc ça n'a
rien à voir avec le nombre d'or
mathématiques
c'est vraiment un nombre spécifique à
l'astrologie par contre c'est pas
quelque chose qui se calculent du coup
c'est le rang d'une année dans un cycle
donc ça se calcule pas donc là ce calcul
c'est idiot complètement invraisemblable
pourquoi elle dit ça et donc mettons
c'est un mec un astronome qui vécut au
vème siècle avant jésus-christ un grec
aux 10 heures bénévoles saluer paix en
jésus le christ considérant infini à lui
être perpétrés à cause d'un tas de
pronostic à sion de louvain fait à
l'ombre d'un verre de vin
je vous en ai présentement calculer une
la plus sûre et véritable que fut ont vu
comme l'expérience ou le démontrera
alors je fais un petit mélange parlant
très anciens et les nouveaux français
donc ne vous étonnez points en tout cas
ici il fait référence à l'université de
louvain qui est une université d'où
sortait bon nombre d'astrologues et
d'autres métiers et vend évidemment mais
c'était une université très importante
au moyen-âge en belgique et donc dans
les sources sans les astrologues que
j'ai pu consulter
pas mal qui sortait de l'université de
louvain dont un qui sortait l'université
de louvain avant qu'elles aient été
créés ce qui est assez exceptionnel
donc là en fait c'est une erreur dans
les archives mais voilà c'était une
université prestigieuse on est là il se
moque de ces pauvres aux universitaires
qui sont apparemment bourg et quand ils
font leurs prédictions et donc ils
considèrent qu'il va faire mieux qu'eux
après ça on a un passage que j'ai zappé
qui explique que les français sont
curieux de nature et qui demande
facilement des nouvelles de leur époque
et c'est ce qui fait qu'ils vont
facilement croire aux prédictions qu'on
lui fait voulant donc satisfaire à la
curiosité de tout bon compagne
gérez vos lever toutes les pentes arches
des cieux calculer les cadrans de la
lune crocheter tous que jamais pensé à
tous les astros fils ip en effet liste
anémophiles as urano pète et ombres fort
ce que sera 10 ou par sue sera passée au
gros amis à tort et à travers et par
adventure adviendra par adventure
n'adviendra me quand il parle des pentes
arches des cieux et les cadrans de la
lune
il fait référence à mon avis à des
choses véritablement calculé en
l'astrologie c'est à dire les maisons du
ciel et les cadrans la lune c'est à dire
les différentes phases de la lune d'un
cycle lunaire et les maisons du ciel ce
sont douze maisons qui compose de ciel
selon les signes du zodiaque et donc la
position des planètes dans ses
différentes maisons avaient une
importance c'est ce qui leur servait à
réaliser leurs prédictions il fait aussi
référence à mon avis encore à
différentes pratiques astrologique
beaucoup moins courante au xvème xvième
siècle quand il nous parle des animaux
fils assurent nos pète je pense qu'il
fait référence aux haruspices aux aquam
anciens au pyromancien tous ces gens qui
avaient des pratiques dînatoire basées
sur la lecture des entrailles
prédictions à partir d'observations dans
l'eau dans le feu bonjour mais les
cendres et ça en fait ça n'était pas à
pratiquer et au moyen-âge en tous cas
presque pas mais ça figurait encore dans
les textes et enfin il se mouille pas
trop puisqu'il termine son texte en
disant par adventure sera viendra par
aventure ce n'adviendra pas en gros a
pas trop prendre de risques après sa
prédiction est divisé en thème
donc le premier thème sera du
gouvernement et seigneurs de cette année
chapitre premier quelque chose que vous
dites c'est fou astrologue de l'ovin de
new-bell de tubage et de lyon ne croyez
que cette année et autres gouverneurs de
l'universel monde que dieu le créateur
lequel par sa divine parole tout régi et
modèrent donc le gouverneur de cette
année est tout autre selon notre
véridique résolution sera dieu tout
puissant
il ne mourra saturne mars le jupiter
notre planète c'est retenons les anges
du bessin
les diables vertus efficace puissance ni
influence aucune si dieu de son bon
plaisir ne leur donne ce passage là j'ai
gardé même s'il répète un peu en gros
dieu tout puissant du début à la fin
parce que c'est assez inédit dans les
prédictions astrologique il n'était pas
fait référence à dieu tout est du
principe que c'était les planètes qui
gouvernait l'année et ne parlait pas de
dieu du tout même si on devait être
catholique qui en fait mais il n'en
faisait pas mention des éclipses de
cette année chapitre 2
cette année ce montant des clipse du
soleil et de la lune que j'ai peur et
non à tort que nos bourses en pâtiront
inanition et de sens perturbations
saturn sera rétrograde venus direct
mercure inconstant et un tas d'autres
planètes n'auront pas à votre
commandement
il étudie les éclipses même si des
éclipses de cette année mais pas
trente-six écluses par an mais bon les
éclipses étaient des événements quitter
beaucoup étudié par les astrologues au
même titre que les passages de comètes
par exemple ils inventent des termes
mercure rétrograde et cetera un
contretemps qui font référence à des
vrais termes astrologique mais encore
une fois c'est de la parodie donc pour
cette année les chantres iront de côté
et cordier à reculons
les escales belle montrant sur les bancs
les broches sur les gambier et des
bonnets sur les chapeaux les coussins se
trouveront au pied du lit les couilles
pendront à plusieurs par photos de
gilles veissière les pucerons noirs pour
la plus grande part le la fura les
points en carême le ventre ira devant le
cul s'assoira le premier nom ne pourra
trouver la fève au gâteau des rois
on ne rencontrera point d'as au flux le
des ne dira points à sous et quoi qu'on
le flat et ne viendra souvent la chance
qu'on demande
les bêtes parleront en divers lieux donc
j'aime ce passage parce qu'il est assez
drôle et surtout et
assez fidèle à ce qu'on trouve vraiment
dans les prédictions alors pas de
manière aussi grossière
ni vraiment détaillé sur les puces etc
mais dont les prédictions annuel on
avait des passages par exemple sur les
saisons les récoltes le la santé des
animaux et donc ça c'est vraisemblable
on avait des choses voilà des animaux
seront malades les récoltes seront plus
ou moins bonne on aura t'elle telle
maladie il a il le fait en parodiant en
évoquant des idées fantaisistes voire
paillardes grossière des malades et de
cette année un chapitre 3 cette année
les aveugles ne verront que bien peu des
sceaux ou aaron assez mal les muet ne
parlerons guerre les riches se porteront
un peu mieux que les pauvres et les
saints mieux que les malades plusieurs
moutons bourse aux oiseaux ont tous les
canards mourront et ne sera si cruel
mortalité entre les singes de
dromadaires vieillesse sera incurable
cette année à cause des années passées
ceux qui seront pleurés ctic au grand
mal aux côtes et ceux qui auront flux de
ventre et ont souvent à la selle percée
est attendue la comète de l'an passé et
la rétrogradation de saturne mourra à
l'hôpital un grand barreau tout qatar
est écroulé à la mort duquel sera
sédition henry vente relay chat lra
entre les chiens et les lièvres entre
les faucons et canards entre les moines
et les oeufs on continue dans le même
style avec des dispositions sur les
maladies à venir assez évident puisque
les avait mises à mal enfin voilà vous
avez compris aussi l'apparition de la
police vegan qui dit que beaucoup de
boutons bourse aux oiseaux poulets et
canards mourront rtc c'est triste et
enfin une guerre mondiale entre les
animaux qui se souviendra à la mort d'un
vieux punk route
pourquoi pas des fruits et bien
croissant de la terre chapitre 4
je trouve par les calculs de l um hasard
on livre de la grande conjonction et
ailleurs que cette année sera bien
fertile avec planté de tout bien à ceux
qui auront de quoi
mais le houblon de picardie craindre à
quelque peu la froidure lavoine fera
grand bien aux chevaux qui ne fera guère
plus de l'art que de pourceaux à cause
de peces ascendant et sera grand année
2k kroll mercure menace quelque peu le
persil mais ce nonobstant il sera à prix
raisonnable le souci est l'ancolie
croiront plus que de coutume avec
abondance de poires d'angoise et ça y
est on a album hasard il à faire
avant cette fois un vrai astrologue donc
cette astrologue en vrai s'appeler abou
mashup acquis mais appeler abou lazare
par les français parce que c'est pas
parler arabe et il a vécu au 9e siècle
c'était à la fois un maître un
mathématicien l'astrologue un astronome
un philosophe de bagdad et il a apporté
beaucoup de choses à l'astronomie et
l'astrologie puisqu'il est repris
ensuite par les occidentaux
il pense que le monde a été créé qu'en
les sept planètes sont entrée en
conjonction dans le signe du bélier
puisque c'est le premier signe du
zodiaque théorie intéressante donc qu'il
amène aussi à penser que le monde sera
détruit quand c'est cette planète seront
à nouveau en conjonction donc aligné
dans le signe du poisson le dernier
signe donc crayon pour que ça n'arrive
pas avant la dernière saison de game of
thrones dans ce texte on a aussi une
référence des casseroles d'après mes
recherches ce sont des blattes
pour votre information de l'état
d'aucune jean chapitre 5
la plus grande folie du monde et de
penser qu'il ya des astres pour les rois
pape et gros seigneur plutôt que pour
les pauvres et souffreteux comme si une
nouvelle étoile avait été créée depuis
le temps du déluge ou de romulus ou
faramond à la nouvelle création des rois
tenant donc pour certains que les astres
se soucie aussi peu des rois que des
lieux et des riches comme des marots je
laisserai les autres fous pronostiqueurs
a parlé des rois est riche et parlerait
des gens de base et à est effectivement
la plupart des prédictions comme je
disais était destiné à des personnages
importants des rois des princes des ducs
et donc même si elles montraient
généralement des dispositions pour
l'ensemble de la population à travers
les maladies à venir les famines à venir
ben elle était plutôt destiné aux
puissants
j'aime bien cette petite pique à
l'encontre des autres astrologues que
fait rappeler en l'expliquant qui lui a
dédié cette prédiction aux pauvres aux
décors et donc il va parler des décors
par planète en expliquant qu'elle décore
seront régies par quelle planète durant
l'année par exemple sature régie
rappelle types de personnes jupiter
régira tel type de personne on va pas
faire toutes les planètes donc j'ai
choisi l'exemple de mercure à mercure
comme piper trompeur affineur teracles
ignore la roumanie et batteurs de pavés
mettre des arcs décret tistes
crocheteurs harpe ailleurs remastered
hâte leurs joueurs de passe-passe
enchanteur bielher poète et scoreur de
latin father de rébus papetier quartiers
bas gatti écumeurs de mers feront
semblant d'être plus joyeux que souvent
ne seront quelquefois arriveront
lorsque nous en aurons talent et seront
fort sujet à faire banqueroute
s'il se trouve plus d'argent en bourse
que ne leur en faut voilà donc dans sa
prédiction ici chaque planète à son lot
de métier et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne retrouve pas trop dans les
prédictions
souvent elles nous font des prédictions
d'ordre général comme on l'a vu jusqu'à
présent et ensuite par mois ou par
saison mais pas par planet de l'état de
qu'un pays chapitre 6 le noble au
royaume de france prospérera et
triomphera cette année en tout plaisir
et délice tellement que les nations
étranges ou volontiers sertir remis à
laurent construire des murs petit banque
est petit et battements mise joyeusetés
ce qu'ils feront un chacun apprendra à
plaisir on y vit on que tant de 20 ou
plus friands forcera vent limosin force
châtaignes en périgord et dauphine et
fort ce livre en langue got force
sablant volonne ce que les sables
d'olonne s'était déjà tout rester fort
ce poisson en la mer fort c'est toi le
ciel force celle en brouage planté de
blé légumes h frittage jardinage beurre
l'étagé nul peste nul guère nuls en 8
brins de pauvreté brin de saulcy brin de
mélancolie
toutefois sur le milieu de l'été sera à
redouter quelques venue de puces noir et
chaussons de la devinière à des o'neill
inspection ni par tb à tous mais les
faudra à force de collations aux
expertises
bon on a compris l'ensemble du texte
c'est rigolo on reste dans la parodie
il fait référence à la devignère par
contre qui est sa maison la maison j'ai
visité donc sa maison natale et donc
dans la devinière ça va pas très bien se
passer puisque on aura les puces foires
et des chaussons même temps les
chaussons c'est bien en hiver quand du
feu italie roumanie naples 6 ils
demeureront où elle et toi l'an passé
espagne castille portugal aragon seront
bien sujet à soudaine altération écrin
train de mourir bien fort autant les
jeunes que les vieux
et pourtant se tient donc chaudement et
souvent contre on leur véhicule s'ils en
ont des quatre saisons de l'année est
premièrement du printemps chapitre 6 en
tout cette année ne sera qu'une lune
encore ne sera tel point nouvelle vous
en êtes bien arrive aux autres qu'ils ne
croyaient mi dieu qui persécutait sa
sainteté divine parole ensemble ce qui
les marsiennes mais allez vous pendre il
ne sera autre lune que celle laquelle
dieu créa au commencement du monde et
laquelle par les fier de ça dit sacré
parole a été établi au firmament
pour lui réguler les hommes de nuit en
fait le nombre de lune en astrologie ça
fait référence au nombre de lune plein
pendant l'année sauf que qui le prend au
sens littéral le nombre de lui donc
évidemment il n'y en aura qu'une c'est
ballot à propos vous verrez cette saison
à moitié plus de fleurs quand toutes les
trois autres sans déconner on a au
printemps je vous rappelle à bil bil de
l'été chapitre 8
en été je ne sais quel vent kurram et je
sais bien qu'il doit faire chaud et
renier vent marin toutefois si autrement
arrive pourtant ne faudra renier dieu
car il est plus sage que nous et c'est
trop mieux ce que nous est nécessaire
que nous mêmes
je vous en assure sur mon honneur
quoique dit ali et ses suppôts bofur à
se tenir joyeux et boire frais là c'est
intéressant parce qu en est t il fait de
nouveau référence à un astrologue arabe
harry à bach haendel là je ne connais
pas son vrai nom arabe donc c'est un
astrologue qui a écrit pas mal
d'ouvragés sur le sujet et qu'on
retrouve dans les bibliothèques du cal
et royal au xvème siècle
j'ai passé les ducs l'elysée vraiment
mais voilà c'était classe il les avait
par exemple dans la bibliothèque du
louvre en 1423 on trouve 16 livres de
ali à bach haendel
j'ai compté les ducs de bourgogne en
avait aussi on va passer à l'hiver
directement parce que l'auto n'est pas
très intéressant d juste de faire
attention aux arêtes si on mange du
poisson de l'hiver chapitre 10 en hiver
selon mon petit entendement de seront
sèches ce qu'ils vendront leur paie 10
et fourrure pour acheter bois et ainsi
ne faisons les antiques comme témoigne
sa baignoire
s'il pleut ne vous en mêlant collier
quart-temps - aurez vos de poudre pour
chemin tenez vous chaudement redouter
les cathares buvait du meilleur
attendant que l'autre amendement et de
chier plus dorénavant au lit au
poulailler faites vous vos ni temps au
fini j'aime beaucoup cette manière de
terminer son livre filet encore une fois
il fait appel à une caution scientifique
en la personne d'ahmed zohar qui n'a
sûrement rien à voir avec ce texte mais
qui était un médecin en al-andalus donc
l'actuel espagne au xième siècle
en guise de conclusion j'ai décidé de te
comparer cette horoscope à une vraie
prédiction que j'avais sous la main
éternellement je vais donc il s'agit
d'une prédiction destiné aux ducs de
bourgogne philippe lebon pour l'année
1464 et qui a probablement été écrit par
jean de védas
on n'est pas tout à fait sûr d'ailleurs
pour l'anecdote gens de les halles c'est
le grand-père de andré vésale un médecin
célèbre du 16e siècle
et ouais bravo papilles et donc en fait
cette prédiction est appelée révolution
barricades
parce que la terre a fait un tour
complet autour du soleil c'est une
révolution comme pour rappeler la
prédiction présente les choses à venir
de manière générale avant d'aborder
l'année 1464 mois par mois et non pas
planète par planète comme le faisait
rabelais et ensuite elle comporte trois
thèmes la disposition des bétails la
disposition des corps humains et enfin
la disposition des moeurs des gens on
retrouve aussi des exemples d'événements
à venir parfois très détaillé et parfois
très généraux ce qu'il faut pas trop se
mouiller et non plus mais sera pour la
première partie beau raisonnablement et
seront en aucun jour vendu midi ou
d'occident est possible qu'après aucun
show soit parfois tonnerre tempêtes et
vents et en fait c'est presque comme
rabelais du coup sauf que là c'est une
vraie prédiction ils restent très vagues
parce qu'il connaît la météo donc il
sait qu'en mai il fera chaud mais qu
aura du vent se mouille pas trop ce type
de prédiction comme on peut le voir
n'était pas non plus une prédiction pour
une personne même si elle était destinée
à philippe lebon elle n'aborde pas le
cas particulier de philippe le bon pour
ça il y avait plutôt les almanachs
annuel c'est encore un peu autre chose
ou là c'était vraiment par rapport à la
date de naissance de la personne à la
seconde près donc la position des
planètes dans le ciel au moment de sa
naissance que les astrologues réaliser
ce type de prédiction est donc là
vraiment on était dans des prédictions
pour une personne pour une année c'est
pas le cas dans les prédictions annuel
là il fait vraiment des prédictions
général que le duc auquel il est destiné
une vision globale de l'année on peut
noter aussi qu'il commence sa prédiction
en mars et ce n'est pas anodin si le
ciel est divisé en deux parties de 30°
chacune selon les signes du zodiaque un
peu les douze maisons dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure même si elle est
redevable petite nuance entre maison est
parti mais j'ai jamais trop compris
laquelle le soleil les traverses en une
année en commençant par le bélier ce qui
explique le fait que la plupart des
prédictions annuelle débute au mois de
mars quel que soit le calendrier en
vigueur et en terminant par le poisson
quand il parle de la disposition des
bétails cette fois il cite des signes
par exemple la rétrogradation de mars
or la fin du sagittaire
la conséquence concernent des boeufs
chevaux et mulets mais je sais pas
exactement ce qui va leur arriver
j'ai pas réussi à tous les chiffres et
en fait si vous voulez essayer je vous
laisse l'image de l'écran un petit peu
et enfin pour la disposition des moeurs
quand il aborde la planète mercure
il cite album hasard encore lui ça fait
tellement plaisir de le revoir
donc si on compare les deux l'oeuvre de
rabelais vraiment une satire une parodie
des prédictions mais on voit bien qu
rabelais connaissait parfaitement les
codes des prédictions qui était réalisé
un siècle plus tôt
et encore au 16e parce qu'il réutilise
vraiment exactement ces mêmes codes en
les parodiant j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu c'est une idée qui m'est
venue quand j'ai découvert l'existence
des portails ruines pronostics à sion
j'ai pas lu le livre sur le sujet j'ai
vraiment fais juste à partir de mes
connaissances d'un petit peu de
recherches et j'ai trouvé ça agréable
comme vidéo donc comme je les dis sur
twitter cette vidéo devait normalement
sortir en octobre
mais j'ai pris du retard avec l'épisode
de septembre donc j'ai décidé d'inverser
parce que celui là était évidemment plus
facile à tourner puisqu'à par a'liénor
un tu t'emmerdes annaba est donc en
octobre on se retrouve pour une vidéo
on retournera dans l'antiquité et qui
devrait être très bien quand je
réussirai à la tournée sans problème de
micro pour terminer comme c'est la
première vidéo que je tourne depuis que
nota bene va faire un gros coup de pub
je tiens à remercier a notament aînés
déjà et toutes les personnes qui sont
abonnées depuis j'espère que ce que vous
avez vu jusqu'à présent vous a plu est
ce que vous continuez à devoir de
manière mensuelle
la plupart du temps vous plaira toujours
et en bonus pour terminer cette vidéo je
vous offre des prédictions de rabelais
pour les gens en régie par venus du
pouce et des femmes
lol à venus comme maquerelle
mario les bougres un bragard nappe le
échancrée ribes leur revient quénard dié
chambrière d'austalie nomine à mouiller
héros
des initiatives hier août une gérer
advocat tiers tavernière buhan d'hyères
frais pierre seront cette année en
réputation mais le soleil entrant en
cancer et autres signes se doivent
garder de vérole de chambre de piste
chaude poulenc rené etc
les nonains apuanes concevront sans
pénétration viril bien peu de plus elles
auront dans ma belle les appétissants
[Musique]
on